Jamia looks like something landed there
extremely quickly and skidded to a halt
maybe something had crashed here the
crash theory gains traction when
investigators discover the image is
taken close to the site of one of the
world's most catastrophic aviation
accidents so when you think about
something crashing in that part of the
world you think about the worst air
disaster in New Zealand history at 7:21
a.m. on November 28th 1979 Air New
Zealand flight 901 takes off from
Auckland Airport on a sightseeing tour
of Antarctica
the crew report clear weather and good
visibility but as the plane nears Mount
Erebus a strange and terrifying optical
illusion known as a whiteout deceives
the two pilots it's not a storm it's
simply a situation where there's white
everywhere white glacier beneath white
clouds above and there's no way to tell
what's up what's down and what's in
front of you at 12:49 p.m. the plane
plows into the ice killing all 257
passengers and crew
BAM they just smashed into the side of
Mount Erebus traveling hundreds of miles
per hour for the pilots it must have
been horrifying those last few seconds
realizing that out of nowhere a
mountainside was looming in the cockpit
window analyst Mark Dantonio studies the
image to see if it could be a remnant of
the plane's long debris trail he
discovers something isn't right when you
first look at this it looks as if
somebody was scraping along in the ice
and making this gigantic furrow but if
we look at this object over here this
little spire of rock you see the shadow
which way it's going well there we see
the shadow as well this is an elevated
feature this is an elevated feature too
the shadow indicates it is not a
depression in the ice but something
rising above it
nasa scientist dr. kelly brunt travels
to the remote feature she finds a seven
mile long wall of jagged ice protruding
from the frozen seas of McMurdo Sound
just like an ice cube in a glass about
10% of the ice is above the surface and
the other 90% is below the surface the
massive ice wall is a rare type of
glacier called an ice tub created by
millions of tons of ice flowing from the
base of Mount Erebus into the frozen
seas